you've written a book prime time and in
the book you you talk about uh aging
and you say that in in your opinion uh
sex life
is very important that as one gets older
if you choose to remain sexually active
a lot of people don't and that's fine
too right but if you want to remain
sexually active it can be a real good
thing but you have to understand what's
happening to your body how old are you
i'm i'm
i'm 28.
i i am 51 years old turn 51 in april
well you know especially for guys age
can have a you look good by the way for
you
thank you very much you keep saying that
and i'm liking it a lot
i'll be right here if you need me
um you know age can have more of an
effect on men's bodies because how so
you think it's tougher for men to age
sexually than women
it's just that if you don't
or if you aren't aging successfully in
that department you can see it
i mean you either get it up or you don't
right
and
women don't have that problem
so you don't really know about women but
you guys have the pills that you can
take well first of all stop gesturing to
me about these
i don't know
i found those pills i didn't get a
prescription i found them
i thought it was a a supplement um
no first of all so you're saying that
yeah a guy has to perform right and as a
man ages you don't i mean that's what
you think you have to do it's much
better if you don't but the big problem
wait back
you've got to go slower here uh
that's the point you think yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
so you're saying that a man doesn't have
to perform later in life it doesn't
matter if let's say there's a guy no
this guy that's for sure
cause everything's tip-top down here
but let's just don't laugh let's just
say
that a man is not able to perform at a
certain age you think that's okay
no i mean it's the notion of performing
oh my god i have to which is there's
nothing you know better than to keep it
from getting up is to think oh my god i
have to perform
rather than just
getting into it slowly i see so forth
but you know given the age you are i'll
give you a little bit of advice okay
taking
taking the pill
popping a pill on the way home and then
are you married
i i was until we started talking
but now now everything's in flux right
now just say what you're since i've met
yes i'm i'm very happily married uh
beautiful wife liza two kids okay so but
you're getting on there so you pop up
close we didn't know i haven't played a
pill
never tried that oh you haven't i
haven't tried that pillow when you do
yeah here's what not to do okay you
don't want to pop a pill on the way home
swing open mom a honey i'm here
i'm ready
you said mom oh yeah oh well you said
mom
now that's what i'm
thinking now i need a pill
or even worse you get home and your mom
is really there
mom's visiting mom
i'm ready to go baby
mom
no but i listen i'm getting old and my
brain is scrambled what i meant to say
was
honey
honey honey you've popped the pill right
and so yeah get a honey i'm home right
let's go right
okay
that's bad yes because just because
you've now taken the pill and you don't
have a problem and you can get it up
foreplay slow
you know
i'm saying this because it's very
important because a lot of men think
that that as long as that they can
perform yes that it's all as long as
they're in a chapter in there about how
you have to really
learn about pleasing the other person
taking your time take your time and if
you've taken a pill and you're you know
you've got a towel rack there you can't
but seriously you can't there's no time
for wine and like it depends why you
have to this is really you know the
whole idea when you get older you'll
find out you're just around the corner
stop saying
i'm a young vibrant man
you look young and vibrant actually but
you just told me how old you were
51 in dog years
[Music]
anyway uh so you but you're saying that
this is coming up you know the whole one
thing about age is the spontaneity thing
kind of goes out the window and you have
to plan which in itself could be
exciting actually right you know and you
have to decide
how long from now am i going to want to
be able to perform and then it depends
on what kind of pill you take
then then you have to factor in the the
foreplay how do we get on this anyway
i'm here to talk about that i just want
a big award and i'm talking to him
by the way this is my favorite
conversation in a long time so
i am very happy and i'm learning a lot
and you're also selling your book it's
not just about the boner
that's the chapter oh
my more recent book is for teenagers and
there's a lot about sex for teenagers
and it's really good it's a great seller
right so you have covered the age range
the whole spectrum yeah